you have three sons I do now these are
these are young kids well they're eleven
twelve and seventeen okay growing up now
what is it like to have three free boys
how's that age you have a son right I'm
told I have a son and a daughter yeah
I'm going to see them when they're each
21 we agreed upon no I have a a
fourteen-year-old daughter and I have a
a twelve-year-old son I can't imagine
having three boys that age it must be no
easy I would think it's noise at me
what's going on in your house they are
they run around Morris what's that nerf
nerf Oh a lot of horse yes yes my eye
this morning my 11 and 12 year olds have
requested lakhs for their bedroom doors
because the 17 year old keeps coming in
and shooting them when they're on the
toilet and in the tub
shoot anyone a toilet that is the lowest
of the low oh I know there's no rules to
nerf war but I think the toilet is a
sacred today you would think you're
sitting that or the door busts open
bandoleros of the nerve there nerf
bullets everywhere right and what do you
or do you roughhouse with them do you
play with him do you play games do they
like sports what are they like yes and
no I mean I did make this place this one
big rug was the place where they could
wrestle and they could karate and they
could do everything and then I got the
foam helmets and everything as they got
bigger and there was a point because
they started doing karate kids when they
were like three and four right and there
was a point where because I'm a martial
artist where I'd be like okay you can
spar with mommy that's right you're very
good yeah well and then there was a
point where they suddenly I was just
getting kicked and I was like oh you're
hurting mommy yeah I'm familiar that my
son used to you know playfully like I
would sort of wrestle with him and he
would punch straight out like that and
I'll never forget there were it was an
age I would say between five and eight
where he was at genital height he was he
would just beat he thought it was funny
to just go BAM right down yeah I got one
right in the hip I just got a hell of a
kick in the hip point I'm and I was like
oh you're good you're good
good you're hurting mommy I think you're
beating mommy now yeah and so we sort of
slowed the roll where I was in the
wrestling match right it was the time
when my when my older son picked me up
and carried me around the house where I
was like I think we're getting past a
certain point here when your son can
carry you if you have to stop fighting
him yeah I think that's a good rule yeah
you